how to write an amazing credo so one of
the things that I talk about in my book
is obviously finding your one word the
one word that defines you that makes app
you are that you can make all your
important decisions through and one of
the most important exercises in the book
that I guide people through is how to
find their credo and the credo is is
basically your mission statement it's
what you're all about it's a better
breakdown of how you see the world and
it always flows from your one word so
under your one word what I encourage
people to do is find three things that
define what that one word is for them
and often there's something that is
super obvious that is the general public
perception of what that word means and
then you need to add two things to it
that make it more meaningful for you
that turn your word into the hashtag
word from believe the hashtag believe
because it's something that you are now
owning that is extremely special
important to you and then all major
decisions that you have to make in your
life and business flow through this and
so I've talked about it for myself
I wanted to share another example with
Alex who helps run in Toronto dine salsa
with me his one word is belong and he
wants to create a community where people
feel like they're welcomed he wants
people to feel like they belong at
Toronto dance salsa but also in his life
people around him should feel like they
belong with him and it stands from him
not feeling like he belonged earlier on
in his life under hashtag belong for him
comes validation comes non judgement and
comes open arms and that's what makes
belong for him and why it's so important
is because it's it's had a tremendous
change on how he treats people in his
life as well how he executes some
business so validation is really really
important to him it makes up the first
arm of belong for him the more he
validates people the more he's gonna
feel happy the more he's gonna feel like
he's contributing and so we worked that
into his phone script where every time
somebody calls he needs to validate them
and now practicing with every
conversation that he has that's you know
of a certain length five minutes plus
you have a conversation with somebody
validate them for something that they're
doing for
joining the class for taking the time
for having the courage to talk to him
whatever it is validation is so
important to him and makes up his one
word that consciously make an effort to
validate people not doing it by accident
allows him to have a greater impact and
makes him happier as well the second
part is judging being non-judgmental
right and so it's super important for
now him to realize I don't want people
to feel judged
I don't want people to feel like they're
judging me and so I shouldn't judge
others and I need to make a better
conscious effort not to judge other
people for the decisions that they're
making in their life and the third part
is open arms welcoming when you first
meet Alex right he has a positive vibe
and he's welcoming and he wants to learn
he's trying to create a connection with
you and so all these things have helped
a lot in the growth and development of
him as a human being and we've applied
that to the business and here's what
happens when you figure out what your
one word is and you figure out the Credo
you figure out the three things
underneath that then you kind of explain
and now that becomes the way that you
operate your life what often happens is
at first it's scary and almost
disappointing because you realize that
that one word that you have is bold is
big is something that you you know are
but also aspire to and you'll recognize
the sad part of it is you recognize that
there's a lot of areas in your life that
are not congruent with who you should be
the reason why you're sad unhappy not
getting the results that you should be
not feeling fulfilled is because there's
too many areas in your life in your
business that are not aligned with your
one word and with your credo so if alex
is not validating people on a consistent
basis he realizes that that that's not
congruent with his one word and he's not
gonna be happy and so whenever you do
figure out your one word and figure out
your credo it forces you to look at your
life and the business and the things
that you're doing and immediately
recognize the holes and where you need
to step up on where you need to really
make the hard decisions to be true to
what you're all about in your one word
it's an exercise that I've taken a lot
of the people on my team through it's
obviously an exercise in the book but
one of the most powerful things that you
can do is when you figure out you're in
one word
and then the three things that define it
for you has believed for me means three
things believed for you maybe something
totally different that's okay but this
is this should be the operating manual
now for how you live your life with
intent with purpose so that you feel
fulfilled and so you're having an impact
instead of just kind of floating through
life and reacting to what's around you
so let's get to the book and updates and
questions we are now at whether we are a
hundred and seventy four we're now at
174 pre-ordered sales from audiobooks
and ebooks and hard copies I still feel
like that's not a lot I still feel like
we should be doing way more of the
people around there saying well for
where we are in terms of the timing
that's that's pretty good it feels like
a big letdown to be honest but I'm
hoping in that that last what are we you
know and almost in a September as we get
closer to Christmas season and the
release date that picks up it's a little
sad disappointing but also you know I
believe I'm I'm I'm the thing that's
getting me through all this is I love
the content of the book right like the
book is solid the book is so good and I
know if people read it and apply it's
gonna have a major impact on their life
and so that's what's getting me through
but I appreciate the support and helping
build it up okay to the questions or
rest day 2103 Haven about your book
can't wait to get it here in France I've
looked at the book web page and I think
there are really some issues on it I
mean it could be much better and your
book deserves that I think I've studied
UX design web design development so I'm
sure this comment will help you and he
basically goes on about all this
feedback for the website about the
display on mobile too much content to
read you want it to be fast and easy
quotes at the top of the page so it's
from Hugo Hugo really appreciate it I
think it's probably too much for me to
digest right now but I'm gonna go home
and look at it and see what may we might
be able to do to apply it and I really
appreciate the detailed feedback that
you gave here that that can help I'm
feeling the love Thank You Man
next up connect baton met baton I
pronounce that okay probably didn't can
I get you work in German language or
your ebook in German please give me an
answer and thank you so much for your
YouTube channel I'm gonna send this to
my publisher I don't
so right now we've been looking at
opening up the market so that you can
buy it the English version at least on
different platforms so Amazon in
multiple countries and the audiobook now
on audible multilingual we haven't
really addressed yet so I'm super
curious to figure out what the plan is
for that thank you for that I'm gonna
send it out to my publisher and see what
they have to say about it I don't know
about the audio version because I want
to do the audio version and I know I
wouldn't be able to do a good job in in
German yeah I don't know if I want to do
a German audio version I need to find
the right person but definitely for the
hard cover if we're opening up language
rights and options I'm gonna forward
this on and hopefully we can do
something I can't guarantee that this
will be ready pre-order but I'm gonna
send it to them if you guys have
requests ideas again everything that
comes in that you want to change you
want to see happen I send it out to the
publisher and so I really appreciate the
feedback and that's like your ideas help
move the needle right it's because of
you guys that we moved it to december
instead of january it's because of you
guys that we got the audiobook available
is because you guys that we've opened up
amazon in different markets so keep
sending the feedback and I keep sending
it to them
next up choreographic arts I want the
audio book as well you know what I just
went back to ESL class so I think we'll
be good to have my first English book
that I can make notes and write on your
book definitely will help a lot Thank
You Evan wow that's that's pretty
awesome Coria
for my book to be the first English
language book that you have that'd be a
massive honor for me and and I think
given the life-changing nature of the
book I think I think it'll be a big win
for for both of us so thank you for that
that I'm I don't even know what to say
thank you for that honor and I'm super
appreciative and look forward to you
getting the copy and it changing your
life next up Sean it's not about the
people you know it's about the people
they know don't worry about selling a
low amount of books person 102 might
have a corporation that needs your
advice stay motivated
I appreciate that Sean if I'm sad or a
peer not motivated I think it's
something that I mean all of us go
through if you have a product that
you're trying to sell and you have a
goal and you're you know you don't see
that the the path is getting there fast
enough you get a little bit down the
thing that gets to me isn't person 102
working in a big corporation it's
knowing that the people who pick this up
are going to make major changes in their
life because I've seen it from the
people that I've helped through the
process and I know that even if it
doesn't spike in pre-orders once it's
out and people read it it's gonna have a
big impact they're gonna want to share
it they're gonna want to buy copies for
their friends are gonna want to use the
information or I'm just you know just so
full of myself yeah but I've seen it
work and so I really believe that it's
gonna be a success because they've seen
it work but where we are now in the
process is getting the pre-orders
through and just like anything else like
if I want to get a million subscribers
on my youtube channel and I'm not there
by the timeline that I set for myself
it's a bit of a letdown but it doesn't
mean I'm not gonna keep going right this
is coming out I work for this this is
gonna make an impact this isn't just
promote it once and then forget about it
there's a lot of stuff in here that I'm
super proud of I want to walk through
you know with my kids and grandkids it's
a legacy for me as well it's something
I'm always gonna be proud of I really
appreciate the concern because I know
that's where it's coming from and any
kind of lack of a parent motivation is
really just a little bit of sadness for
not reaching the goals yet but I'm still
very highly motivated for getting this
thing out and getting into the hands of
entrepreneurs
next up Safi ox by the way I ordered
three copies of the hardcover version of
the book not the audio version I love
that thank you so much I don't know if
we've tracked that sale so make sure to
please email in the receipt and for all
you guys buying I mean our numbers that
I update on are the ones that people
have sent in the receipt so otherwise we
don't really have a good way of tracking
it so that'd be super helpful for those
of you who are buying sending your
receipts we can track the numbers and
also you get bonuses you get shout outs
part of the benefit of doing this so it
helps everybody and for anybody who's
bought and has an email in the receipt
please make sure to do it soon next up
dear Han or Diahann bought the audiobook
at audible also will purchase a hard
copy thrilled to be able to support you
directly you are anointed to do what you
do
god bless you and yours richly thank you
for that thank you for buying the audio
version looking forward to buying the
hard copy I appreciate that support it
really really mean
a lot to me I'm excited because in two
weeks I think I'm gonna go in and start
recording the audio version and so I'm
already getting ready I'm fired up and
ready to go and record it you know thank
you for that and all the you guys like
knowing that you guys have bought the
audio version fires me up more so when I
go into the studio like all of these
people are counting on me I insisted on
doing this myself I gotta bring the fire
I gotta bring the fire so your your
comments are in my ears I'm already
writing I'm already psyched up to go and
do it so you guys are firing up and I
really appreciate it
next up relaxing sleep station when I
see a specific bonus ends the top of the
page it has no relevance to me as I look
as a warning because I don't know what
package it is a part of and I don't want
to go searching through other packages
to work it out because of that I'm not
as concerned about the fear of missing
out because I don't immediately connect
with that bonus that relates to me so I
think this reference to at the top of
the landing page there's a there's a
time bonus that expires every day so on
different days or different bonuses that
come out that if you buy you know within
that day you get that bonus and if it's
a different day you get something else
so that's some good feedback it's
something that we've tested I put up
stuff like how I got Gary Vaynerchuk to
endorse my book some other you know
super important questions that have come
in from entrepreneurs that I spend time
making a good video about just answering
that question and going deep so people
who have that problem can benefit from
it we've gotten pretty good feedback on
those bonuses but I it's great like I
love that it's not working for you it's
great to get that kind of feedback and
hopefully turn it into making the page
even better so that's it for this week
thank you guys so much for your support
for your feedback I'd love to know from
you questions that you have about my
book about the book writing process
about the topic that I started with
about creating the Credo and finding one
word making it really meaningful and
powerful for you leave that in the
comments below and I'll do my best to
answer next week for you I also want to
give a quick shout out to Hugo Hugo
thank you so much for buying a copy of
my book and for the awesome feedback you
gave me about UX design in the comments
I'm gonna check that out again when I
get home for those of you watching if
you want your chance and a shout out in
a future video make sure to pick up a
copy and email in your receipts that we
can
keep track thank you so much for
watching thank you all for your amazing
support continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon